mai nur sprang unsere feinde ich den
sieht auf hindi urheberrecht mein name
ist luca herzlich willkommen wie heute
zu einer neuen episode von lukas leute
stunde
ich habe vor einiger zeit einen beitrag
auf seite eins gesehen wo es um einen
jungen ging der mit einer schweren
krankheit zu kämpfen hat seit einem jahr
hat der 13-jährige moritz in aggressiven
tumor in seinem gehirn und im
hintergrund lag einen smiley kissen aus
meinem shop daraufhin haben wir kontakt
mit der familie aufgenommen und moritz
vor einigen tagen überrascht und zu
hause besucht sondern habe ich moritz
gefragt was er gerne so viel videos auf
einem kanal schaut und er hat gesagt ich
würde ganz gerne
moritz gefallen meine reaktion auf video
anwendungen von euch daher habe ich mir
gedacht reagiere ich heute mal wieder
auf ein paar witze von euch doch bevor
ich jetzt gleich auf die witze reagiere
möchte der moritz noch kurz jemanden
grüßen
die klasse 8a favorisieren die
englischlehrerin wird auch gedrückt ja
okay jetzt geht es los mit dem video war
lukas leute stunde geht es darum dass
ihr meine zuschauer auf instagram videos
posten können unter dem hashtag lokal in
dem ihr ein witz erzählt und das habt
ihr vor einer woche schon mal gemacht
nachsagen
steven rack ist scheiße
die flasche ist ausgelaufen ja mal
schauen ob die witze diesmal besser sind
nie heißt lukas kawka
der sohn die mutter mama rief die mutter
antwortete daraufhin ein wachsen der
sohn sagte daraufhin ich fange an zu
kochen
in jedem fall viele wölfe
den fand ich sogar grün das ist echt
waren sie da kommen uns ersten typ an
der irgendwie sagt kavka was so der
komplette schwachsinn einfach ist dann
kommt ein anderer junger der sagt seine
mutter würde nicht kochen und der dritte
wird bei dem ich dann wirklich sache ist
einfach nur nennt man viele wölfe
wolfgang also mein humor ist glaube ich
echt querschnittsgelähmt
wenn die preise steigen ihr seid doch
das denken
schlechten rasen kann man nicht wegen
herzrasen hh
wow
kein herzrasen nicht mehr kürzen schule
am schatz ich fühle mich in letzter zeit
zu retten täglich braucht dringend ein
kompliment juli zu lukas eine gute
beobachtungsgabe
wisst ihr als ich wenn diese serie
überlebt habe habe ich mir gedacht da
kommen wirklich rasse witze an wo sich
leute wirklich gedanken gemacht haben
stattdessen werde ich einfach nur fertig
gemacht
denn da steht sogar auf fotos geil alter
hat er meinen merge rumliegen aber
beleidigt dann meine mutter und meine
mutter bei aldi force ist am nächsten
tag alles 18 treffer geil alter kaum
hast du vielleicht noch in deine
mutterwitz für mich jemand eingebrochen
und natürlich bruder geil freut mich ein
stimmiger gute witze hier wieder
ich bin
du wirst vermöbelt wenn du bei ikea
klaust kriegen wir zwei sätzen
kriegen sich zwei graz in die haare
auch umringt da verstehe ich dass mich
mal eine dicke frau ging zur bäckerei
sie mein tipp schweren kugeln der bäcker
antwortete darauf aber nicht in meinem
laden wird kannte schon
was ist gelb im profil wenn man es hier
ins auge schmeißt
ja
was
ach so ja da hätte ich auch drauf kommen
können was sagt der spanier
der kauf ist und ja sagt sie
also das wird für den witz da bekommst
du wirklich von mir den ring der woche
herrschaften sehr hoch geplant sagte
eine ostern zurück
der andere ist es wasser geben dass wir
noch nach
hhl mir vier körperteile aktien als maul
aus gesicht also das ist bei mir leid
also zu beginn von sonderfolge ist das
kreuz levels ck hier weil ich mir halt
denkt okay da ich muss mir wieder witze
anhören und am ende ein erfolg ist es
schon hier so also wir sind gerade ca
auf der höhe kann sich mit grüßen
nein und können ausländer kein
fußballspiel weil sie kein pass bekommen
ich fühle mich scheiße dass meine
mundwinkel dabei so ein bisschen hoch
geben ich hoffe ihr versteht das hier
alles nur spaß ist und dass wenn jemand
sagt deine mutter irgendwas dann geht es
natürlich nicht gegen meine mutter oder
wenn er sagt ausländer bekommen keinen
pass so das ist als alles nur humor so
also wir sind nicht gegen ausländer wir
sind nicht gegen frauen nicht gegen
mütter nicht gegen keine ahnung war es
fragt das kind den vater papa wo hast du
denn hier habe ich als kinder ein
gespendet ob das kind entführt und wieso
denn antwortet der vater natürlich
besser wohlfühlen straße gemein
das ist wirklich gemein aber irgendwo so
lustig in russland wirklich so krass ich
glaube das ist er dieses typische
stereotype denen die nicht loswerden so
wie die deutschen nicht loswerden dass
alle denken dass wir wie die bayern sind
somit lederhose und birnen
na da bin ich ja gespannt die klasse 5a
schreibt eine klasse denn fragt yamaha
was fragt der tim denn den jona kann ich
mal ein finger haben nun das fragt warum
du hast doch selber ein das frage ich
mich jetzt tatsächlich auch ich weiß
aber meiner macht so viele fehler
oder nicht oder nicht
das war dein witz warum fragst du mich
dann oder nicht ich habe diesen
zugerufen dass man belegt achtung kacke
wer dir denn der humor geschossen luca
du bist ein schatz du gehörst vergraben
die so wie sehr ich gerade mache meinen
usk runter gefallen dass ich kann sie
nicht ausgehen
mithin urheberrecht vor nein nein nein
ach du scheiße was tue ich mir denn was
passiert wenn luca ein laden betritt es
geht sofort dann auch mehr
[Musik]
ich liebe die tochter claudia
sag mal was vorsingen daraufhin
antwortete tochter ab die gäste schon
angehen sagt die mutter stimmt aber dann
schnell genug gehen sitzt hätte ich
tatsächlich schon allerdings in einer
gewissen anderen ausführung also erzählt
weise so witze werden ja dann oft
irgendwie anders weiter erzählt
allerdings sehe ich dass das video noch
ein bisschen länger geht ich bin das
mädchen aus dem letzten video maschine
er war
moment
die treppe runter
nein ich sage die stimme wer von einem
kleinen jungen gewesen als
wiedergutmachung werde ich dir jetzt auf
instagram folgen hier
ich bin mir grad gefolgt sieht man das
ja es ist es fokussiert das ding sich
willkommen häufig videos eingesetzt wo
sich leute nicht selbst filmen wollen
ist natürlich auch völlig verständlich
hat auch keinen bock meine herzliche
fresse abzufilmen auf jeden fall kann
ich da nie genau zuordnen bei gerade
stimmen von kindern
ob das jetzt eine junge oder mädchen
stimme ist
als er sie sagt sogar noch was kauft
lukas ein mensch weil er braucht geld
weil er muss sich alkohol
ja
sie sagt ihr sollt man
das kaufen
keine schlechte idee ist allerdings sagt
sie danach dass ihr nur mein merge
kaufen sollte damit ich mir shampoo
leisten kann weil ich so stinke
isch en folgte gleich wieder wenn luca
sich schneidet ist er dann ein
schnittlauch
lustig
ganz ehrlich dieser gerät noch hat mehr
kästchen ist während sein das ist
definitiv korrekt leider
[Musik]
weil der film erst ab 18 ist
dafür bekommst du einen applaus die
nennt man einen dünnen frosch magerquark
magerquark
alle kinder gehen auf toilette packen
außer frage
der schweiß in den schrank
kann ich dir doch mal höheren energien
aus bettlaken aus der scheiße in den
schrank endet der witz ist so ähnlich
aufgebaut wie dieser wolfgang wirthmann
viele wölfe mussten wir richtig stumpf
einfach runter gerattert feiere ich aber
war dass das zweite mal dass ich dieses
mal wirklich gelacht habe mit ihm gibt
es im supermarkt oder im supermarkt gab
es eine aktion der 500 begründet muss
nur 1 euro für den einkauf zahlen
fritzchen war dessen platzte aber er hat
sich leider nur ökonomie für 79 cent
gebraucht
ja
könnte auch ich gewesen sein an der
stelle wird das heutige video ist
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren wenn es euch gefallen hat und
euch diese serie lukas noll stunde
gefällt das gerne mal ein leichter
schaffen
40.000 like dass eine hohe zahl aber das
zeigt mir einfach hey luca wir feiern
das wie du dumme auf witze von einer
dummen lu crew reagiert ziemlich dumm
alles tatsächlich falls ihr irgend einen
lustigen witze haben dann filmt euch
gerne und dadurch das video auf
instagram mit dem hashtag lokale hoch er
mir könnten auch gern folglich heißt der
laser luca und dann kommt die eventuell
in die nächste folge von lukas leute
stunde
[Musik]